Ace became a top commander on a yonko
crew Luffy became an emperor himself in
just over two years and Sabo Rose to the
position of Commander in Chief of the
Revolutionary army with the sole purpose
of taking down the world Nobles but what
if instead of seeking freedom from the
world government all three boys instead
joined the Marines together in order to
make the world a better place that way
and of course this story simply must
begin back in the Goa Kingdom where
these three boys originally grew up now
from chapter one on we know that Luffy
was inspired to become a great pirate
when he was safe from certain death by
his mentor Shanks however we also know
that during that time GARP had been
training Luffy as well well if you can
call throwing him into the jungle or
tying him to a balloon training I guess
with the specific purpose of turning him
into a top-notch marine and we can
pretty much assume that he did something
very similar with Ace since he raised
him as well however both of them were
dead set on becoming pirates in the end
but for this scenario let's him imagine
for a second that something really
fundamentally changed about their
childhood maybe GARP was actually a good
grandparent for a change and actually
spent some time with the boys which made
them then want to follow in his
footsteps or what I personally think
would be a much more likely situation
could have been that the village where
Luffy grew up in might have been
attacked by a ruthless and cruel band of
pirates and so I think it's reasonable
to assume that Shanks is out at Sea so
there is no one to protect the village
and we could even say that these Pirates
might have Set Fire to the forest on
Mount corvo which would affect ACE also
since he was living up there with the
mountain Bandits and so with the Pirates
running free there is no hope for the
village until this Marine Admiral pulls
up on his chilly bicycle and casually
wipes out all the Pirates which would of
course be a major turning point here
because it would show Luffy and Ace just
how important the Marines could be to
this world and so this single moment
ultimately inspires them to become
Marines in the future as well and I also
think that the boys could have also
pretty easily convinced Sabo to join the
Marines with the them since Sabo already
has a very good heart and wants to free
people as well which he can easily do as
a marine and so of course since he
doesn't want to become a pirate here
we're gonna assume that he doesn't set
out to see on his own and he doesn't get
himself blown up now interestingly
enough we actually don't know for sure
what age exactly people can join the
Marines in one piece but we do know that
this pink-haired boy was 16 when he
first joined so let's assume that older
teenagers can actually join the Marines
and so just to keep things easy let's
say that Ace and Saba would join when
they're 17 which is the same age that
Ace originally set out to become a
pirate as well and of course if these
two are joining the Marines there is no
way that Luffy's staying behind so GARP
is forced to let the 14 year old Luffy
join as well and as these three together
begin to climb through the Marine ranks
there are a few important things to keep
in mind here first Luffy would very
likely still have the straw hat but a
major question we will have to answer
later on is just how long Shanks will
actually let him keep that hat if he
actually remains a marine secondly you
might have very serious doubts about
Luffy ever actually following someone
else's orders but this is where I should
mention that their personalities would
probably be slightly changed as well
Luffy at this point would still be
adventurous but if he knows that he
wants to be a marine he would probably
eventually get used to the idea of
taking orders from someone else also Ace
will still be hot-headed and cyber would
of course still want to free people from
oppression just like they do in the
original story plus even though they are
supposed to follow orders do you really
think that this is going to happen all
the time we'll see how long that lasts
also keep in mind that the timeline is
also not the same as in the normal story
since Luffy didn't start his pirate
Journey for another three years into the
future and so of course let's kick off
this Marine adventure of the three where
every recruit begins life as chore boys
because very much unlike when GARP
personally started training Kobe I think
that Garb would be very much sick and
tired of these three troublemakers at
this point so they would just be
assigned to these random Navy bases and
start at the very bottom of the Marine
ranks however you know as well as me
that this probably wouldn't last very
long because these rambunctious kits are
probably so awful at doing normal chores
that guard would probably just throw
them into battle since they aren't good
for anything else at this point and so
it's off to the ships to fight pirates
in the East blue and I do think that
they would stay this way for at least a
couple of years working their way up the
ranks from chirboy to semen recruits
because of their impressive fighting
capabilities also one other major change
here would be that Ace of course most
likely wouldn't get his fire devil fruit
since he only found it after setting out
to see to become a pirate this means
that Luffy is the only one of the three
with an actual devil fruit not that it
matters though because they are all
insanely strong and capable of taking
out random Pirates though I do wonder if
Ace would eventually choose to use a
sword or another bladed weapon if he
didn't get his original Fruit however
this simple life in the East blue can
continue forever though so let's say
that two years have passed Ace Ensemble
are now 19 and they have been promoted
to Petty officers while Luffy at age 16
remains a seaman first class and now you
might be wondering Manu Kobe moved from
being a recruit to being a captain in
that exact same amount of time so
shouldn't these three monsters move up
way faster than him which I'd say is a
fair point but also do remember that
Kobe had personal training from Garb so
that with the help of garb's
recommendations he probably moved up the
ranks a lot faster than normal Plus on
top of that Oda probably had to somewhat
keep Pace with pirate Luffy's warp speed
advancement as well which isn't the case
in this scenario however no worries
because that is all going to change very
quickly because we have to remember that
in any military organization you can
stay with your friends forever and so
it's at this point after two years that
the three childhood friends are split up
for the first time Sabo is being sent to
work with the awful Captain Morgan at
shellstown which is not going to turn
out very well as we'll see in just a
moment Ace is assigned to Lieutenant
Commander full body and Luffy is going
to be assigned to Commodore pudding
pudding but even though the boys are
separated now I can just imagine that
they would still all want to compete
with each other to see who can get
promoted the quickest especially Luffy
since he is already behind the other two
and now keep in mind that even though
Sabo is a marine he would still have a
strong sense of doing what is right so
when he's put under the command of the
abusive ants for being honest straight
up Evil Captain Morgan I don't think
that Saba would put up with it for very
long and while I'm not very sure if this
marine version of saba would challenge
Morgan to a direct fight because of
marine regulations I do think that he
would definitely collect evidence and
submit a report to the marine higher-ups
and then I could absolutely imagine
Morgan finding out about it and then
trying to just straight out kill Sabo on
his own which would of course be the
perfect chance for sabot to then Crush
Morgan and get him kicked out of the
Marines and let's shift over to Ace now
because if he's working with full body
then they will probably be dining at the
floating restaurant baratier quite
frequently which is absolutely perfect
for Ace who can eat his fell during his
visits here and I think he would also
have a chance to run into some pretty
strong Pirates Who are coming for a
tasty grub as well and even though it's
still about a year before Dawn Creek
shows up in the normal timeline Ace can
still get a reputation as a defender of
the floating restaurant which would
probably make him pretty good friends
with Sanji however while the older two
are making names for themselves it is
Luffy who truly makes the first major
Splash as a marine because let's say
another year has passed and now we're
basically caught up to the main timeline
at the start of the actual series now
Luffy is still working for pudding
pudding which eventually brings him to
arlong park just like what happened in
chapter 75. however while arlong easily
killed all the Marines back then this
time they do you have Luffy with them
and while it might be tough for Luffy
alone to fight all of the arlong Pirates
by himself we have to remember that he
has already been out at sea for three
years now and should be quite a bit
stronger than he was when he actually
started the story in the normal
storyline and so in his heroic moments
Luffy wipes out the entire arlang
Pirates and saves nami's Village on his
own which means that he would likely
befriend the orange-haired Navigator who
would then very possibly join the
Marines as well since her Village is
safe and her adopted mother belmare was
also a Marine in case you forgot and so
while we're still missing out on most of
the other straw hats at least Nami is
joining Luffy in the Marine wrecks and
now these heroics got Luffy promoted up
to the rank of enzyme that you can see
on the list here and he's not the only
one because Ace and Sabo have also
scored their very own impressive
victories now for example Sabo and his
new Commander Ripper here have gone and
rescued orange town from the invading
buggy Pirates and ACE also takes out
Dawn Creek when the starving pirate
tries to take over the baratia
unfortunately though no one is around to
save usop's Village so sorry usop fans
once again it looks like this tradition
of dying in these what ifs just
continues which does mean that Ace and
Sabo are now joining Luffy in the lowest
rank of officer in the Marines oh boy
let's just uh hope they don't actually
get to give orders to anyone but with
this promotion come new assignments Ace
and Luffy are both placed under Captain
smoker in loketown while Sabo is
assigned to Captain Hina who is already
on the grand line and even though smoker
was actually originally happy to stay at
loketown in the original story I think
that with his new two recruits
constantly annoying him to go to the
Grand line he would probably sooner or
later agree just so these two would shut
up about it and so now that we finally
made it to the Grand line Ace Sabo and
Luffy are going to move through the
ranks very very quickly so as we'll see
very soon it's not always in a positive
direction because while they Patrol the
Seas under their new captains I like to
imagine that Luffy still runs into Vivi
at some point maybe they also come to
Whiskey Peak and meet her there but
whatever way it happens Vivi would very
likely still tell them all about her
country's troubles after seeing how
strong Luffy and Ace truly are and of
course Luffy and Ace would want to go
right away to take down the Sandman but
smoker says they cannot interfere with a
warlord because they're basically immune
from the Marines however the captain at
least thus agree to go to Alabaster just
to be around in case anything goes wrong
Sabo and hinang also arrive there and as
the Civil War kicks into high gear the
three boys simply cannot sit around and
let all of these innocent people die and
so in their very first major Act of
insubordinance Ace Sabo and Luffy work
together to take down sir crocodile
which they somehow managed to do even
though he is a logia fruit user and
Luffy might actually also run into Robin
and although she wouldn't let him become
her friends Luffy would probably still
let her go you could even mention that
if she's looking for a crew to help her
then maybe she should try to find Shanks
but we'll see exactly how Robin's Story
Goes later on in this video actually for
now though this whole situation of
course causes a major headache for the
world government and these three Marines
are headed for a ton of trouble because
even though the rulers of alabasta
officially thanked the three boys they
are still demoted back to Warrant
officers oh whoopsie however at this
point the Marine higher ups see very
great potential in all three of them so
I do think it makes sense now they were
each assigned to an admiral for special
training Yes you heard that right which
is going to supercharge their
advancements just like we saw when Garb
started training Kobe and they would
likely pair up the two most hot-headed
so Ace would go with a kainu Luffy gets
paired with kizaru by the way I would
absolutely love to see how this training
would go since they're both pretty much
air hats which leaves Sabo going with
aokiji which is actually also very
interesting because aokiji just like
Sabo is starting to have some very
serious questions about the corruption
in the world government system and so
this means that they would definitely
learn basic hockey I also think that
Luffy would develop some of his gear
techniques which all result in a huge
power boost for all three especially
because they now have the fundamental
tools to fight with any devil fruit user
in the grand line and so while these
boys are getting their own personal
training Arc let's shift to other events
going on in the world for a second
because even with a Sabo and Luffy all
in the Marines I still think that
Blackbeard would very much be able to
backstab this guy and steal his Darkness
logia fruits and then from here and out
you would still have the exact same plan
to become a warlord however this time
instead of being able to capture Luffy
as was his original plan or take out Ace
when he came for Revenge Blackbird will
have to find some other way to convince
the world government to actually make
him a warlord and so to keep things
fairly similar to the original events
let's assume that he still targets
members of the Whitebeard Pirates maybe
he takes out some of the lower ranking
commanders and this increased level of
aggression could see someone like Marco
the Phoenix come after Blackbeard and
then if Blackbeard could capture him and
hand him over to the Marines then we
have all the ingredients that we need
for another Marine Fort although as we
know Blackbeard would have a way harder
time sneaking into imple down to break
out the level 6 prisoners since Luffy
isn't there to cause a massive prison
break though the darkness fruit user
might also be able to come up with some
other plans such as the hypnosis user
Lafitte somehow sneaking in and causing
Their Own Prison Break whatever way it
would go with Marco taking Ace's place
on the execution stand Whitebeard would
still very likely come to try and rescue
his right hand man which perfectly sets
the stage for Ace Sabo and Luffy to
demonstrate their new powers in a war
that unfolds much differently than the
original story because now we have to
keep in mind that Marco was a key
Fighter for the Whitebeard Pirates
during the war he even took on Admiral
so with him on the execution stance that
is a major loss for the Pirates plus
none of the input down prisoners that
actually help Whitebeard and while I
don't think that Ace Sabo and Luffy are
ready to take on Whitebeard yet I do
think that they would do very well
against the white bit commanders such as
jozu Vista and easel perfect power level
for that which actually all results in
the Marines winning this fight a lot
easier than in the original story Marco
actually gets executed sorry which
honestly pains me to say since he's one
of my all-time favorite characters
whitebeard's defeat doesn't change which
once again allows Blackbeard to swoop in
and steal his devil fruit and although
it's possible that this time the Marines
may be able to keep Blackbeard away I
believe that this was Blackbeard's
ultimate goal all along so I do think
that he would somehow figure a way to
get this done which of course means that
this is where things turn dark because
with Whitebeard dead I think that akinu
and other Marines would continue to
fight against the remaining Pirates
causing way more Bloodshed than in the
original war and of course this is
particularly hard to take for someone
like Sabo or Luffy who would probably
hate to to see lives needlessly wasted
which does mean that everyone would be
very relieved when Shanks finally shows
up to stop the war however this might
not actually be as good for Luffy as you
might think because remember that
Chang's trusted Luffy with his legendary
Straw Hat because he assumed that Luffy
would become a great pirate and he
likely even knew that Luffy had the
potential to become Joy boy so now that
Luffy is clearly established as a marine
we have to ask ourselves what would
Shanks do at this point well I do think
that the most likely thing after he
stops the fighting is that he gives
Luffy a very severe warning he would say
something along the lines of that hat
belongs in the hands of the future
pirate king and he might even demand
that Luffy leave the Marines or give up
the hats which of course brings up a
very interesting dilemma for Luffy now
he was inspired by Shanks as a kid but
eventually decided to become a Marine
after seeing evil Pirates attacking his
village so while I'm sure that he still
feels some call to Adventure here in
this scenario he will reject chenxo's
warning and stay a marine which leaves
Shanks with two options one try to
eventually convince Luffy to become a
pirate or two to kill him so that his
devil fruit can be reincarnated however
at the same time of course just can't
see Shanks taking out Luffy right here
especially after he just stopped the
fighting so for now he Zips in steals
the straw head back and then leaves
which would still leave Luffy Furious
but he would probably be held back by
Sabo and Ace and now with Marine sword
over Whitebeard is dead and his crew is
shattered Blackbeard is basically a
yonko at this point and a Sabo and Luffy
are all promoted to Captain based on
their Feats during the war and this
promotion actually grants them a little
bit more freedom and their own ships and
Crews and the first thing that they do
with this freedom is subscribe to this
channel which you can do very much as
well by pressing that shiny red
subscribe button under this video
however there are even more changes
coming to this world because even though
there wouldn't be a two-year time skip a
kaino and aokiji would still have their
legendary duel aokiji would of course
still lose and leave the Marines which
of course would be a major blow to all
three of the boys since aokiji as you
might remember saved Ace and Luffy back
at the beginning of this storyline and
the icy Admiral was of course the one
who personally trained Sabo so I wonder
if we'll see him again later now that of
course means that we have some new
Admirals to pick as well and while Luffy
immediately volunteers he is passed over
but don't worry just wait until you see
the truly epic battle that actually
earns him that promotion later on and
now this does take the boys into the new
world where they really start to shine
over the next two years they battled
countless strong Pirates growing
stronger and developing their hockey
Luffy and Ace might also finally unlock
their contrast hockey at some point
though it has never been confirmed if
Sabo has this ability as well and they
might actually have also become friends
with Zorro who in this timeline has
become a very strong Bounty Hunter
actually funny we haven't seen any of
those ones before and between Zoro and
the three young captains they make
something of a competition out of taking
down members of the worst generation
like hit who's particularly ruthless the
straw man basil Hawkins and even perhaps
jewelry Bonnie who the Marines were
extra focused on recapturing and over
time all of these Feats eventually see
them rise to the rank of vice admiral
not that bad for a bunch of teenagers
but just wait until you see what comes
next for now I think Luffy might
actually also meet Rayleigh at some
point and just like Shanks I think that
the former right hand of the pirate king
would try to convince Luffy to become a
pirate once more which at this point
might actually be starting to look a lot
more attractive to Luffy especially as
he sees more of the corruption of the
world government for example he might
want to take a more active role in
taking down the yonko but the Marine
leadership just won't let him however
Luffy says orders be damned because when
he Ace in South
and they see all of the horrific things
that doflamingo has done I can't see
anyone stopping all three of them from
taking down the corrupt Warlords and
while once again this does save the
kingdom their actions draw the Wrath of
the fleet Admiral Akainu just like
fujitora did in the original story which
gets them banned from all Marine bases
for the moment however of course this
doesn't bother them and I think around
this time they would also reunite with
the former Admiral kuzan who tells them
a little bit about why he left and what
he's planning to do in the future at
this point Luffy and Sabo are tempted to
actually join him especially Sabo but
Ace convinces both of them to stay and
remain loyal to the Marines because Ace
in particular doesn't want to leave the
relationship that he has developed with
many of his comrades in the Marines
however the more time Luffy now spends
in the new world the more tempting it
actually becomes for him to learn about
the one piece which means that when
kuzan leaves them with one other very
important piece of information they
immediate immediately set off to their
most important Mission yet because
apparently kuzan has met with Nico Robin
and she has been secretly going around
collecting information on the so-called
pornoglyphs kuzan tells them where she
is and that she would like to see Luffy
again because she has some information
that she wants to give him so hey Sabo
and Luffy go meet up with Robin and this
single event is going to have major
consequences for the three boys but
especially for the entire world because
when the boys finally meet her on some
random Islands they are met with a
shocking surprise Blackbeard and his
crew have also arrived and are
ransacking the entire Island trying to
find Robin and this instantly puts Luffy
Sabo and Ace into battle mode and they
square off against the actual Blackbeard
Pirates but with just the three of them
against a yonko crew I would probably
have a very hard time coming out on top
however this is just the start of this
Clash because kuzan who at this point
has rejected Blackbeard's invitation
shows up as well also help the three
Marines and he is not alone because even
though he left the Marines he still
wanted to bring peace to the world which
led him to warn the Marines that
something might happen on this island so
not only does kuzan arrive but also the
three Admirals kizaru greenbel and
fujitora they all show up to stomp out
the yonko threats which let's be real
even though its Blackbeard would
definitely turn the battle into the
Marines favor that is of course until
another major player joins the conflict
as well you see ever since Luffy Ace and
Sabo took a doflamingo the yonko kaido
has been out for their blood as well
because they ruined his artificial devil
fruit production and let's say he
somehow follows them to this island and
joins this insane battle which honestly
for that Island at this point rest in
peace it's probably going to be
destroyed but at the end of this battle
it does bring some hope for the future
because I do think that the three
Admirals together would be able to
combine take out kaido but not without
suffering casualties plus Blackbeard is
known for backstabbing so I think it's
fair to say that even though kaido gets
taken out all three Admirals are killed
but of course this would leave our three
young Heroes who at this point would
surely have awakened some of their
Advanced hockey although I'm not sure if
Luffy would ever unlock tier 5 as a
marine but at this point I think they
are Admiral level fighters on their own
so their combined strength plus the help
of kuzan should be enough to eventually
defeat Blackbeard and end the entire
battle which absolutely would throw the
world into chaos I mean two Emperors
defeated three Admirals killed the
entire world would be in shock however I
do think that the Marines would wisely
promote Ace Sabo and lofi to Admiral
right away since they're now basically
the strongest Marines on that level and
even though these three might be tired
of the corruption of the world
government at least as Admirals they
might be able to have some real
influence on the Marines and most
excitingly this probably also means that
Ace and Sabo gets to pick from the world
government stock of devil fruits
although we don't know exactly how that
process says Works regardlessly they
would probably grow even stronger with
new overpowered devil fruits but now
with the world in absolute chaos the
race to find the one piece heats up even
more and as Luffy's out finding the
flood of pirates seeking the treasure he
is met by none other than red hair
Shanks quiz come with once again another
challenge if Luffy can defeat Shanks
then the red hair Captain will leave him
alone for good but if Shanks wins then
Luffy must leave the Marines and chase
after the one piece because Shanks
believes it is his Destiny so if you
want to see exactly how this legendary
battle between Luffy and shang's might
go you can watch this video right here
thanks for watching and I will see you
in the next one